[Music]
this is festival foodies where we go to
fairs across the country and try three
things a fan favorite a hidden gem and a
wacky snack
then we pick our favorite this week we
take on the la county fair
let's dig in
[Music]
i'm aj and i'm allie and this is
festival foodies today we're at the la
county fair los angeles has some of the
best food vendors in the country and
we're here to try them all ellie county
fair has been around since 1922. the
fair attracts over 1.3 million people
within 19 days you get to see over 500
food vendors and taste over 1200 food
items large turkey legs fried oreos we
have it all here at daley county fair
first up is the fan favorite so if you
look on the instagram page for the la
county fair the number one thing you see
when scrolling are these giant colossal
curly fries i just need to see how
they're made let's get in there let's do
it so this is my 31st year at the la
county fair welcome to biggie's this is
one of the biggest and best barbecue
stands at the la county fair
we do it right and we make some amazing
fries through the course of season we'll
use several rail cars of potatoes as
fast as they're pulling them out of the
ground we're cleaning them and we're
putting them in the fryer no one's ever
trusted me in the kitchen before but uh
thank you for your trust our colossal
curly fry cone has been a huge hit
because i think not only are they
delicious but they have really great
packaging it's a giant 18 inch cone we
fill it all the way up with fresh spun
fried curly fries they are really really
good you know what i'm just going to go
for this one
cheers
oh my god they're really cooked to
perfection it's a little crunchy on the
outside but then really you taste the
fresh potato i can tell that this is the
potato that i personally spiralized not
only are they delicious but they're also
super fun like who doesn't want to walk
around with a giant cone of french
absolutely my favorite part is keep your
eyes on the fries that's exactly what
i'm doing all day
[Music]
well these fries are clearly delicious
and a fan favorite but you know the bear
better than anyone where can we find a
hidden gem you should go see my friend
chicken charlie he's on the other end of
the fairgrounds ooh that sounds good you
ready aj oh you know i'm ready
have fun guys thanks
[Music]
next it's time for our hidden gem we
found chicken charlies i was just
looking at this menu and they have a
deep fried oreo a donut triple
cheeseburger oh and i heard they have
chicken and waffle on a stick oh now you
know i gotta try that so chicken
charlie's has been part of california
ferris for over 30 years we've been
selling chicken and waffles for a long
time so charlie thought why not put it
on a stick let's make it easy so we took
chicken tenders put them on a stick bake
them right into the waffle so that you
can hold it up eat it while you're
walking enjoying the fair it was a huge
hit
so easy so convenient and absolutely
delicious oh my goodness
so how does one even eat this what you
got to do is just rip it in half just
like this
[Music]
there you go all right it's right here
[Music]
oh my god it's like a giant chicken
finger inside of a giant waffle i don't
know who wouldn't love this you're at
the fair
and you want to eat something throw it
on a stick my favorite bite
when you get a little packet of syrup
and powdered sugar with the chicken
that's why we did it we wanted it on a
stick all in one bite
what do you think that is over there
that looks fun oh i think that might be
our wacky snack let's check it out yeah
last but not least our wacky snack
we found nitro treats number one fan
what'd you get today i got unicorn bread
oh how does it work teach us okay so
first you just gotta bite it
oh
are you a real dragon
you come out to the carnival and the
fair for an experience you don't just
want to eat your food you want to play
with your food so that's kind of our
little slogan play with your food so our
candy popcorn which is our nitro candy
pop we make it from scratch right here
cowboy kettle corn and we use all the
flavors of cotton candy so we have blue
raspberry cherry grape and we also do
caramel and green apple so when we dip
in the liquid nitrogen it gets really
crispy and really light we also have our
unicorn's breath which is the cereal
balls that are colorful and bright so
when you first bite into a nitro treat
you notice that there's smoke and vapor
coming out of your nose of your mouth
some say their ears it's gone crazy with
social media because they could really
express like what's happening you could
not only see on their face you could see
it coming out of their mouth okay dragon
dragon breath time
[Music]
all right i gotta try this
[Music]
you were good at it i'm bad at it the
experience of the nitrogen like just
coming out dragon breaths is so weird
it's like cold coming out your nose like
you can barely eat because you're like
laughing so much i can totally see why
this booth has gone viral it is so fun
to play around with and an instagram has
been
[Applause]
i think we ate too much to do a roller
coaster that day
i'm so full we had so much delicious
food today but i have to say the
colossal curly fries were my favorite we
got to watch them being made fresh and i
love the cone that they come in it's so
cute with the slogan keep your eyes on
the fries which we did by the way
so what was your favorite so as much as
i love the fries i have to give it to
the chicken and waffle on a steak i just
never seen it in that form factor before
it was super easy to carry around the
fair and the chicken was delicious
mixed with the sweet syrup and sugar it
was just it was perfect just like our
day at the la county fair we'll see you
at the next one stay hungry
[Music]
oh that was horrible
she's a loser
[Music]